[Music]
we are all natural born learners
full of determination we take
unimaginable risks
exploding with curiosity we achieve the
extraordinary
but as we grow up our love for learning
is put to the test
some are told that they are not good
enough or are given up on
while a few strive many begin to see
their natural curiosity fade away
or begin to associate learning with
anxiety
children can't do much about that but
adults can
we can educate ourselves and change the
experience that kids have in our homes
and classrooms
that is why we have built a school for
little people and share everything we
learn along the way
that's why we make videos that explain
complex social psychological and
pedagogical ideas to new parents
students and teachers
and that is why we publish all our
materials via the creative commons
license and allow anyone to freely use
them for all sorts of educational
purposes
today one million people have subscribed
to our channel over 50 million people
have watched our videos and our channel
is sprouting up in several major
languages
your views your likes and your
meaningful comments are what keep us
going and we want to thank every single
one of you who helped us get here
on our website you'll find all videos
for download plus additional resources
and classroom activities
if you want to support us join our
community and become a patreon and help
us change education
one mind at a time that's patreon.com
sprouts
[Music]
you